let's say it cost you a million dollars
it's not the money Mark let's say it
took you a year and a half I don't want
to SP a year and impact an entire Next
Generation to have what you a logical
way of looking at it yes you need to be
more logical sometimes I want to be
emotionally connected to the projects
that I'm doing you may be missing
tremendous opportunities for the things
that just don't make sense all of the
stuff that you could make the team you
could have the people you could hire the
culture you could have the brand that
you could have the the downloads or the
offers or the things that you do right
like if you didn't worry so much about
the data driven decisions you don't know
if they're not two or three or four
degrees separated from a really cool
outcome cuz like the office took a
season and a half to find its voice it
just takes time to figure out and CRA
The Not So less heart more head well no
I that's why you suck I suck cuz I'm I'm
too fashion
driven tell me why I suck we are back
with one of my longest friends Mark drer
who was a branding expert and I bring on
uh people who kind of kick my butt and
tell me why I suck at different things
and through my discomfort and pain and
awkwardness hopefully you guys learn the
process too so Mark runs what do you do
Mark uh I run sales Loop we are a
branding agency we help B2B businesses
mostly service based seven a figure
businesses sell more so sales Loop is
the new company but you've been doing
this for 20 years or something yeah I
started in 2006 it was 23 yeah and I
thought I know I can quit my job even
though my daughter only a week old and
my wife is at home and has no money I'll
I'll quit my job and start my own
company cuz I'll make so much more money
and and eventually that happened but it
took five years to get there and you
were there for a lot of it was good it's
been a ride so I I bring people on they
tell me why I suck that's that's kind of
the goal you you have an advantage uh
and a unique perspective of being on the
journey for so long you helped me film
my first video you you've been at the
first of a lot of the different things
that I've done so you've seen it kind of
happen and unfold so when I bring people
on you just to give a story and explain
some of the things but you know it a lot
better than than maybe I do too to be
honest you remember more things than I
do so I'm trying to figure out you know
the next steps uh I'm we're growing
we're having impact you know we're doing
the YouTube thing uh as well as training
thought leaders and helping some of the
biggest names the industry but I also
don't know what I don't know and uh just
trying to figure out what don't I see so
I thought let's bring markon and he can
kick my butt well it's interesting
because you know we've I've known that
this recording is going to be for a
little while and I was thinking about
you know all the ways that you suck and
that's a joke but you took that way too
seriously I'm like telling like you like
hit me with it but but no actually I was
thinking I was reflecting on your
journey you know when when we met you're
running uh like a publication and it was
very SEO heavy and then uh you started
to get into video after many years
of because it was 2009 but but video
YouTube had been a thing for a few years
already and you were you know you jumped
all into video and you went all in on it
and I've watched you write your first
book and your second and your third and
your fourth I've watched you go from
saying you know I never want to leave my
home office and I don't really want to
have a team to Growing how many people
are on your team now 42 42 42 people on
your team and the idea of like I don't
want to go out and speak anywhere and
now you share the stage ages with you
know pton Manning and Brandon bashard
and just like all of the biggest names
you shared the stages with and uh you
I've seen you grow your channel from
back in the day where we were looking at
numbers every month and you're like
you're like I I remember I don't know if
I'm allowed to say this but I remember
you going like there's this guy Grant
Cardone oh yeah and and our agent we
have the same agent and I'm going to
beat him to like 100,000 YouTube subs or
I remember really early on you being
like hey this Gary ve guy I'm going to
beat him to a million Subs just watch we
got we got the numbers I I know we have
the numbers right and so I've watched
this journey that you've gone through as
you've grown and so I think this will be
an interesting episode mostly because I
probably do know you better than anyone
else but I also know that that I know
how good you
are at focusing at really specific
things I know when you care about
something you really care about it and
you just do not care about anything else
so when sometimes I'm like oh what about
this you're that's not important to me
what about that's not important to me
what that's not important to me so it's
like okay and then the other thing is
when we when I've come with suggestions
sometimes in the past you're like that's
so small that's so small what no what's
the big thing what's the big thing
that's going to take us to the next
level what's the 10x thing and so I know
is that what you're bringing today and
so I know you well enough to know that
that that this could go along the lines
your natural way to approach things is
like that too small so I'm going to
ignore it I'm not interested in that
right now so I'm going to ignore it I
can't measure it for me not going to get
into ideas here let's go what do we got
okay I'm getting this forward because
audience if Evan starts doing this help
me catch him up oh my gosh okay great
now that we had the five minute Preamble
can we get into what we're doing here
Mark so so what's the thing that's
holding you back right now I don't know
you don't know okay what's the vision
that you have that you want to grow to
you know I have a standard answer but
but no the no answer no the
standard is not is not BS either but
like if if I had a specific thing that I
knew knew knew for sure that's what I
would be doing right like if I had a I
know the bigger picture version but the
Tactical like micro what's the mini I
don't know right so if you look at
what's holding me back well lack of
belief in myself to do the next big
thing what is the next big thing no not
next big thing though like I know that
you have Master like lifetime goal I
know I know that you always want to be
swimming I know that you always want to
be pursuing that but I also know that
you have you know like what you're
working on right now in that three to
five year Vision that you probably like
I don't know do you do you do you have
this like oh man I am working it's three
to five years away but this is what I
want and this is what I'm working
towards but I also don't think in five
year like chunks like that the big
vision is I want to solve the world's
biggest problem right people don't
believe in themselves enough great so
how do I do that well currently and then
I'm open like say hey the the stuff
you're doing currently sucks and you
shouldn't be doing it at all perfect
great what should I be doing set
currently I think the way to address it
for the world is content at scale and so
YouTube primary and then split to the
other platforms after that but content
positive optimistic hopeful believe
content at scale I think is the best way
that I've got to solve the problem and
so that's what we're doing but we could
do it better we could have new shows we
have like that's a big idea and then
inside there's lots of little ideas of
show Concepts and what we could be doing
let's look at the content so the content
is scale uh it's not necessarily
entertaining it's not necessarily super
specific in educational it's
motivational it's inspirational like
like how do you classify it not
entertaining yeah I don't think people
would say entertaining the the the I
wouldn't even say motivational
necessarily but the goal is I would love
for somebody to come and watch the
videos and at the end of each video
believe in themselves more to go and do
whatever the thing is that they want to
do to inspire them to play a bigger game
and feel like I can do this today
because that's what it does for me so
how's that not motivational or
inspirational when I think of the
motivational genre I think of the
motivational speeches and the you know
the running videos and the workout
videos and like somebody yelling at you
and that kind of stuff and and that's a
super successful genre we've maybe done
a couple videos along that ilk of you
know less brown speeches or something
but it's not really the the main focus
of what we do for me it's
it's sometimes the right idea set in the
right way can spark a change and so I'm
trying to capture those moments in ways
that hit me that then I can share with
the audience as well and sometimes it it
pops and does really well sometimes like
I love it and it didn't do so well if
you imagine waking up every day and
you're going to go for a walk and you're
going to pop on in every carmical video
I want you to go from feeling like today
was just whatever another day to like
I'm ready to go get it today
so if you if that's motivational cool I
think the approach that we do it is much
more through ideas or way of thinking as
opposed to just somebody yelling at you
to go do something so maybe the approach
is slightly different but if you want to
call it motivational in that sense then
then cool and so when you think about
the magic you know formula the the
feeling the vibe that makes an Evan
carmichel video not uh one of those
other channels where people are taking
you know clips of movies or music or
other people's speeches and compiling
these these you know three hours of
motivation that will yell at you or some
of the other channels that exist out
there when you think about that thing
that makes your thing yours have you
ever Define that or is it just a feeling
that you have it still comes down to a
feeling but we've put maybe some
guardrails around it or um guidance for
team to also help find because I'm not
finding all the clips we're launching
two videos a day on the English side and
more on the other channels uh so I'm not
looking at every single video and
picking every single clip so it's guard
rail so uh it has to be positive you
know it's not it'd be a lot easier to
grow if we were doing negative content
Trump as a blank and whoever and
reacting to news and all this kind of
stuff right just not interesting and
I've played with do I be the positive
voice inside of those platforms and uh
it's a struggle you know if that is the
thing or not if you ask me if if I could
if I could
grow you know a 100 times bigger and not
do that I'd much rather not do that so
it's about it's about the sharing of
ideas and processes and methods that
then make you want to go do something
bigger and so I try to have the team
pick content too that they get inspired
by like when you watch this you learn
something but not just the tactics of
like how to set up a Facebook ad or
something like that's
educational tactical how too we don't do
a ton of that kind of stuff
it's maybe leaning into the reasons why
you need to get up and go do something
today um but again just sometimes I
guess it's more of a feeling with
guardrails I it's the best way I can
explain it when I watch a clip and I
don't like it I'll let team knows like I
didn't like this because of blank we're
not making major mistakes where it was
just a super negative clip or something
like that um but they don't always hit
the mark and so I'm giving direct
feedback every clip that you pull has to
have a point right like it has to land a
point it can't just be a whole lot of
feeling without having that key learning
that key takeway or land the point
doesn't have to be spelled out all the
time and this might be a difference
between me and other people that the
ability to to see something and feel
something else like to get a learning
from it where it's not laid out y some
of the people we profile are very good
at specifically laying out how to do X
do this do this do this others you have
to re between the lines and say that's
cool how they responded to that I don't
know if I would have responded the same
way they responded even though what they
said wasn't
necessarily great so there's been a
bunch of those clips that I've included
I maybe I could add commentary you know
I haven't done a lot of that but you
know I think um Howard Schultz gets up
on stage from Starbucks and the
shareholder was upset that they
supported I think it was gay marriage or
something or something like that for for
their team or or the first company to
give uh health benefits to everybody
part-time workers or something and one
of the shareholders stood up and said
like Howard like we're a coffee company
why are you making political stances
like just sell coffee dude don't worry
about this stuff and he stood up on
stage and he said well we see the world
through the lens of our employees and
we're going to support them and so if
you don't like what we're doing feel
free to sell your share in Starbucks and
go buy something
else like the CEO of like when do you
see a CEO of a public company do that
right I saw that that's why he's on my
wall at home that one speech because I
was expecting some boring corporate
answer like sorry we'll look into it or
yeah to like corporate speak and nothing
happens right I mean you dealt with tons
of this
it was like no like he tells the
CEO of a public company tells you sell
the shares of my company go buy
something else if you don't like what
we're doing yeah who says that nobody
says that uh and so like I I like that
so we included as a clip but it's not
for what he said it's not for the point
that he made is that he was standing up
for something right it's is like how he
said it that that's what struck me and
so some of the clips are like that do
you ever feel I mean you've established
you've created this this format this
formula you know the top 10 Clips the
top 50 Clips um the these mashups of
different speakers of different people U
and that's not all you do but but but
that's a big that's a big part of it
half the content going up is like famous
people Clips interview and half is me
Solo or mashups of me or interviews or
podcasts or whatever like this is going
to haven't you
done all there is to do in this space no
because there's always new content yeah
there's always new people there's always
new ways of saying things and I need it
like I need it so I'm still making it
but go back to
episode 200 yeah yeah but I've already
seen that even if it's the same person
but they're seeing it in a different
way so are you making this for you or
you making this for your audience
both are you making it for you or your
audience though
both who's more important well I make it
for me and my my audience likes it no
the Evan content I'm not making for me
no people are saying we need we want
Evan like what do you do and so like I
could do a better job on but if you were
making this for your audience and not
yourself would you do anything
differently possibly like like so what's
the goal what does it mean to make it
for the audience if the goal was I want
to just hit 10 subscri right you've
talked about your big massive thing if I
wanted to solve the world's biggest
problem that people don't believe in
themselves and focus just tell my honest
on them and don't bring in
myself I don't even know if I know how
to do that I don't even know if I want
to do that could that be something
that's holding you back uh possibly
because at a certain point a lot of
companies scale out to this level of
like let's call it professionalism right
but but you know you're owner operated
you're you're passionate and you're
going to hit a point where you have to
start doing stuff on mass and um now
this is the downfall of a lot of
organizations and maybe you're so
successful because you're staying so
true to yourself but your desire or your
need to make sure that you're making it
for you and the
audience at a will scale you to a
certain point but at a certain point I
have to imagine that would hold you back
because there's so many more strategic
things you could do if you removed
yourself from it from from from having
this to be so personal possibly I mean
the the thing popping in my head is I
don't know that I would so what's a
scenario something that the audience
wants but I don't want it no no no no
it's not that you don't want it you're
just not making it for you you're making
it for them I'm making it for them but
not for me yes so I'm trying to think of
an example this it was a video that like
I think the audience would really like
but I I'm apathetic to like whatever
just in different whatever it's a piece
of content that goes out because you
know it'll serve your audience you know
it'll serve your mission you know it'll
make you money what's wrong with that I
think what's wrong with that is
uh if that's how I ran it I will would
stop so is this for you or is this for
your audience then well both if you're
consistently doing something that you're
just apathetic about and the only reason
is for your customers but but not you
but maybe it's getting the growth you
want on the mission that you want the
success you want maybe the spillover is
more audience more pull for the stuff
that you do love I mean we we all as as
we see what do you mean the stuff that I
do love well I'm not saying that you
don't make the stuff that's for you and
for the audience so use the growth to
fund videos that I do want to make do
you need to fund anything like aren't
you making already enough money I don't
know what I would do right I remember a
year ago you were at a mastermind group
maybe a year and a half ago and someone
said let's imagine that you have $100
million yeah right do you remember this
question right no but go for it let's
see if my consistent let's imagine you
have $100
million uh and you have to spend it like
what would you do I have no idea what
did I say then no idea well you were
like you were at the time you were like
oh you know I'd probably do this I'd
probably do this and they were all like
like the next few steps but they weren't
the 10x steps right they weren't the
like let's reimagine everything Let's Go
Crazy let's do things just you know may
not always land well but I think I don't
think the problem is usually lack of
money yeah for almost anybody like you
can get money if you have a good enough
idea but are you willing to spend the
money on what I don't have the idea what
am I doing what am I spending money on
that has to come from you well I but I
don't know right like I'm not I'm not
sitting here thinking oh my God I wish
that I could have my own Walt Disney
World and call it believeland and have
rides and like theme so part of our
strengths our weaknesses our weaknesses
our strengths okay right so so the very
strengths that allowed you to build the
40 person team the systems that you've
built the analytics that you have like
like everything you've built has been
the thing that has allowed you to build
what you've built but but it will keep
you from building what could be next
like the fact you don't have a 3 to five
year like man I really want want to do
this like I like I really want to take
this business to here or the fact that
you're like hey here's a $100 million
what would you do next you're like I
don't know it's not a lack of money um
you have massive vision and you have
these really focused weekly quarterly
whatever it might be like the next steps
yeah but but like okay so but if it's
not money that's motivating you but the
way that I like I get an idea and that I
should start going at it too right so I
don't have three to five year goals
because as soon as I get something that
is a three to five goal I just started
attacking it so in in Movie Makers or
The Mastermind or my software company
brand lytics that we're getting ready to
launch it's like okay I'm going to build
this so we're going to start building it
right now it's not like I need to get
these things done and then I'm going to
launch this new idea brand litics is a
perfect example we started working on
that three years ago right we developed
the logo we developed the the the the
name and and early versions of like
let's figure out how to start a
mastermind group and whatnot you took it
to Market really quick I think within
like six weeks you took it to Market
what brand analytics yeah okay did I
yeah because it was a coaching a
coaching coaching thing yeah the
software started at the same time you
didn't wait around for anything right it
became a coaching thing and then from
there it became this thing and then from
there it became this thing and a gr yeah
yeah yeah but when you started brand
lytics you didn't even realize it was a
three to five year fishion because I
don't think you thought it was going to
take you three to five years to build
out and Implement right I don't think of
any timelines either for things like my
YouTube Channel's not a three to five
year Vision like I'm going to do this
forever and
until I don't so I'm going to build
brandal lytics forever until I'm done
with it and then I'm not right that
could happen so that's why you said you
know would you make content for your
audience but not for you was like I
think I probably just quit at that point
like I think I'll just move on to
something I have to love the process of
what I'm doing but see this is why it's
so hard to tell you why you suck this is
why I spent a few minutes early on
giving the audience a little bit of
background about what I anticipated you
would do the answers that you said I was
going to give though but you are though
because you're saying you're saying I
could do that I just don't want to Mark
so are you where you want to be are you
satisfied are you happy are you like are
if you if you you know you started you
started on this journey when you were
what 26 or something because you exited
a software company and 22 Yeah 22 and
you were at and you were you were
speaking at the YMCA yeah
and three people showed up right yeah
that was your first speaking engagement
in Canada yeah and then it became evanc
carmel.com where you had 4,000 authors
and like
600,000 articles on your site I don't
remember where the numbers but it was it
was decent and then that became your
YouTube channel yep and now it's become
speaking it's become you know the the
consultant see you do it's become and it
will continue and you're just going to
keep
going but if you think think about from
22 to Let's okay you're going to live to
100 and you're going to work until the
day you die because you love this stuff
and it fires you up and it feeds you are
you on Pace are you behind are you ahead
like are you satisfied I don't think on
that in those terms of like when am I
ahead of behind on year 100 am I
satisfied you know it's my Canadian
boying answer it's like yes and no right
like super grateful for everything I've
got where I'm at Great okay let's move
that out of the way yeah but it's also
real and and no like I want to build and
grow and do more like not just do the
same thing okay build and grow and do
more do you know or you won't know until
you feel it and hit it no I don't know
if I knew I would do it like I don't
have a problem with starting right we'll
start and we'll we'll like cancel
everything and we're going to go and do
this thing right no that's easy it's the
well what's missing
and I get ideas myself but I also like I
pluck them from the environments right
so like Arthur here is filming us today
and I'm asking him Hey Arthur like you
know we're doing this setup but if you
have any other ideas for what we should
do like how else should I what else
should I do with my brand and he might
pitch me some ideas and I don't like
them okay cool but maybe there's a one
that sticks right if you look at the
companies that I started with b and
Jeremy and Zach and Drew if I look at
Bose for example he Bo you know you you
work with Bo he books guests on people's
shows that started because I was on a
show with uh Brad Lee and Brad said man
he like do you have somebody who can
book and you're like I've got a bow and
I and like I have I have I have people
who help me is like man if you if you
could turn that into a business like I
would I would hire you to to do this or
hire him like can I hire I want somebody
to just book me guests because I'm
having a hard time booking guest so this
is early days of Brad Lee I believe that
how personally attached you are to your
business is your greatest strength and
your greatest weakness sure because if
you want wanted to really impact people
at scale and on mass there would be
things that your company would
do that you would you would scale up
past
yourself uh yes and so the fact that
you're so intimately involved with so
many aspects of your company it just it
just keeps you from scaling it keeps you
from hitting that number that you want
to hit I think the heart and soul is
what I wouldn't give up like I give up a
lot of stuff I don't do most of the
stuff in my company so like almost all
like I wouldn't be here talking to you
if I was solo trying to run my business
right so most of the things I don't do
in my company but but the ideation still
comes from you uh no I love
collaborating right like give me an idea
Arthur give me an idea right like team
give me an idea what can we do how do we
make this better you know AI give me an
idea we're we're working on but but but
you still but you still have to like it
yes yeah yeah yeah but I don't have to
come up with everything and I don't have
to do anything but yes like the heart
and soul I think I would have a hard
time giving up and if you said that that
it well I know I'd have a hard time
giving up thanks to this conversation
and if you said well you have to give
that up in order to hit your goal I
don't I don't know if I want to hit my
goal like to help people believe in
themselves but be apathetic about the
content that I'm or the path that I'm
doing it I don't know I don't know that
I could stay on so the ends don't
justify the means no I have to like the
process and you have to be a part of it
no
I don't have to be I'm not saying you
have to push the buttons no no I don't I
mean lots of things happen without me
but at a certain point everybody who
scales past themselves finds themselves
and I've heard this from from 8 figure
nine figureure entrepreneurs they they
they have to live with certain things
that they know are not at their
standards as uncomfortable as that might
be or not the way they would do it yeah
all the time things are not at my
standards for sure like I'll walk into
anybody's department and be like dude
dud what are we doing here cuz I can
understand not going negative cuz you
want to be positive yeah but let's
imagine because it's a really simple
thing to do I don't want to go negative
I don't want to be negative even though
it'll grow me I go positive but that
same decision you're probably making on
a lot of micro decisions throughout the
day where you're just like it's not my
taste it's not my style I don't happen
to like that I I don't want that I don't
like that and if there are experts who
are who have a vision or filter or an
expertise that you do not have because
you haven't surrounded yourself with
that leadership where they are respons
ible for making those
decisions everything will always be
filtered through your own personal taste
and you'll you'll never give room for
people to do things that are outside
your area of expertise if if you know
what I mean now I know you overcome this
through Partnerships no but skill set
wise I I I'm totally open like I don't
know the cameras and the lights and the
microphone and the gear and like if this
is the right mic or not or whatever we
want to sit closer together further away
like I don't care about yeah I came in
and I was like can we sit closer and
they're like no well cuz we have another
one after this but it's like it's not my
is I don't care I don't like you know
Christina and my video editor is saying
can you make sure that the white balance
is on and we have separate audio tracks
and so I tell Arthur Arthur can we make
sure the white balance is on and like I
don't know what any of this stuff means
or care I want I want this conversation
to go well I want the conversation I've
had in this chair with other people to
go well but a lot of the technical
expertise I'm not attached to if if
YouTube
was winning off of 3 minute videos
instead of hourong videos cool let's go
make three minute videos you know so
like the heart it's the heart and soul
that has to be intact almost everything
else doesn't matter show me that it wins
have you found people who
can lead and Champion that heart and
soul without you pretty close on some
areas so I think the closest
to would be Ivan who shout out to Ivan
who's watching this now uh who is
basically the final filter on video I
don't see a lot of the videos before
they go live actually most videos I
would say I don't see until they go live
any any set video I'm not seen before it
goes live anything that we're working on
is a new brand new thing I'm I I
probably have handson but brand new if
you're doing a top 10 video I'm probably
not seeing it before it goes live that's
because of Ivan Ivan and I every week
for a year looked at videos and he made
he researched and found them and I I
told them I like this I don't like this
I like this I don't like this I like
this I don't like this and of all the
people in the business that I I love Co
collaborating but like that role is the
one has to be the most evid and so now
he's trained two people under him on
doing the same thing so now they have to
do it they're being trained by him and
then he filters it out and teaches them
and then there's still some clips that
like why did we include this but I'll
see it afterwards be like guys number
six was an like I never learned anything
but it's not that it's not that often
that that it's happening so Ivan is is
great uh Nina has also become really
great so Nina runs a lot of the team a
lot of the stuff that's basically
outside of YouTube and the
software Nina's doing everything else
and
so does this clip get posted to
Instagram or not I don't know I don't
see it I don't see before it goes live
most of the time I mean I I might I
might hear something and I'll message
teams like guys include this clip from
here to here because I loved it on
that's why and it goes up and they
usually do slightly better to a lot
better than what we're picking but but
not like smashing um so Nina and Ivan
are the two who
protect uh me from me and do a lot of
the heart and soul stuff it could be
better we could have more ideally like
every new person that comes on they're
learning and they're training and
they're get into the two Nicolo who does
our intros on our videos uh same thing
was like meeting him every week looking
at his intros like yes this no this the
and some of it if he had a technical
reason like no but this doing it this
way increases the retention on the video
and has a better input okay like prove
it show
me and then I don't think I've ever
apart from things like like when would I
say no to the expert or to the
data when it's when it's clearly going
to work but I don't want to do it like
when would I say no it's things like
that like it's negative but I want to do
that but apart from that it's not really
shutting down experts I'll shut down a
lot of ideas but I'm open to ideas right
let just be the right idea at the right
time and the right you know like the
whole Brad Lee thing led to me working
with Bo and we pitch Brad as our first
client he's said he's not
interested you know who was his first
client Steven Scoggins yes because he'd
beat getting the contract signed by like
20 minutes to me so that there was an
idea that came up
that it landed I I don't know how to uh
how to dissect what ideas I like or not
or how to how to how to how to do you do
quarterly planning annual planning to
planning no no you don't have a vision
of what you're building or where you're
going no not how where I'm going for
sure but you don't have your next 10
hires in your mind for you're like man
this is what I need to do no dude if you
have a fiveyear vision for yourself
you're thinking small what were you
doing five years ago that doesn't but
but but the fiveyear vision doesn't
matter matter the five-year vision is
the is the is the current direction for
what is currently Out Of Reach for me my
current direction is what I'm currently
doing right and if I have something
better if if like VR was way better
let's go let's drop YouTube it's all VR
I I did that with mysite this is so this
is so nuanced and and it it may be too
nuanced like like I I don't want to come
across this nitpicking but I'm but I'm
trying to articulate your you're like if
this was better I would do it if the
data says this I would do it if the
expert says this and I agree with it in
this time at this moment I would do it
okay and so there's just I I know that
some of your biggest breakthroughs have
been through play right the top 10 rules
to success was because you were like I'm
gonna I'm gonna show trigger yeah yeah
the top 10 rules video guys was just
because of him yes yeah it became a huge
thing so so and this is this is the this
is the challenge is like I know that you
have for play yeah and I know that your
audience loves the play it's just not
well it doesn't always work too and I
don't know I don't know how much they
love it doesn't matter if it works or
not yeah yeah but I'll still do it yeah
yeah like the top 10 one worked but I've
tried 20 other things that just went
nowhere
and twen dance challenge or whatever
right these like little things that you
do in your business but the top 10 thing
was a little thing too I know it just
became a big thing the the mark drer
Easter at the CN tower everybody
messaged Mark drer did pan out when you
gave an entire Easter long weekend to
get to to mobilize believe Nation
toex say make more content I spent an
entire Easter weekend pinging having my
my my believe Nation ping Mar so I'll do
that stuff but it's like where does the
ideation come from right and like how do
I it comes from me but it also comes
from from Sparks from different thing
like Jeremy saying he wanted to walk my
dog and mow my lawn and wash my car cuz
he wanted to spend more time with me
like obviously I don't need that but
then two months later leads to me
thinking hey maybe I could teach him
YouTube Right which then leads to you
know so those are all business plays
okay well whatever any like any idea
it's it it might Spark from me but it
could Spark from somebody I talk to it
could Spark from a video I watch could
Spar do you do you never feel like
you've and and I asked this kind of
earlier the same question but do you
never feel like you've crack the code
you know what the analytics is showing
you you know what current retention is
showing you you know what works and
doesn't work and it just forces you to
make the same thing over and over and
over again yep when you try new things
as as as fun as they may be as
interesting as they may be the data may
come back that it doesn't quote quote
unquote work because you have like
really data driven decisions that you're
doing yeah and so do you never feel like
you're I mean I don't feel like because
I'm supposed to tell you why you suck
but you may be missing tremendous
opportunities for the things that just
don't make sense I mean there are lots
of things you can do for your team for
your culture for your brand for your
growth for your audience for you told me
5e plans are stupid you have no idea
what you're doing in five years yeah but
but equally the type of content you're
making the the play that you could do um
all of the stuff that you could make the
team you could have the people you could
hire the culture you can have the brand
that you could have the the downloads or
the offers or the things that you do
right like if you if you didn't worry so
much about the data driven decisions you
don't know if they're not two or three
or four degrees separated from a really
cool
outcome do you feel like that holds you
back
or and again I this might be too nuanced
but do you understand what I'm saying no
but I mean we'll do I'll do stuff all
the time that doesn't work doesn't work
but it doesn't mean that I automatically
quit on it okay like the top 10 worked
yeah the shenai twain worked yes I just
didn't want to do it right and back to
like but but like you if you didn't make
stuff just for you but you made it for
your audience you could have you could
have spun this out I could have been the
dance challenge guy but I don't want to
be the dance challenge guy you don't
have to be the dance challenge guy you
could just be part of part of the brand
part of the vibe part of the essence I
don't want to build a dance challenge
Vibe Channel whatever it's not that it's
just but that's the kind of thing it's
like it could work lots of things could
work but but the spark of Brilliance
that you find so exciting yeah is what
makes you so
awesome and if you're not interested in
it you never let it play out yeah if I'm
interested I I have to like the process
right yeah and so that might be so there
could be an opportunity to let these
things that so capture your attention
and so interest you and so spark your
your your audience and people that yeah
maybe it's not going to be forever but
certainly can play out past the one
thing because it happened to catch your
attention that Happ well nothing is
forever though too right like any cut
stuff if it if the data doesn't come
back as a word or I don't like it like
the top 10 I would I I would just keep
doing like I just I love it the top 10
actually was underperforming so we
started what was top 50 right no or not
even anymore I mean
youel cuz the best videos on our Channel
were not actually the top 10 yeah so I
don't know how many years ago we we
pivoted and started a new channel so the
top 10 channel is where all the top 10
stuff is going yeah and I'm doing that
because I love the top 10 and we take
the best ones and put it to the main
channel so like we work strategy around
the heart but if the heart 's not there
or Fades like what's the key to my
longevity is that I still love the thing
that I'm doing 10,000 videos later and
14 years later or whatever I suppose
what what's shaping kind of my um I
guess approach to this conversation is
I've had this realization that that
unless if you're a professional athlete
or a very very uh like famous actor
celebrity singer what have you unless
unless if you're that type of person an
Entre is the only role that I'm aware of
the only person I'm aware of that has
the freedom and ability to hire the
people around them to balance out all of
your
weaknesses right okay like most people
can't do that but we can do that okay
and so you are really gifted at at this
thing and you have Sitting these empty
seats around you of other leaders who
could balance out and and take take Evan
carmichel Inc can take like the office
of the CEO the office of the founder
okay and make it so much more
well-rounded by surrounding yourself
with all of these leaders and then just
just go like I have a deficiency here
but think about how much stronger a
company would be if I had this I'm GNA
give it to you I'm Gonna Give You
programming I'm gonna give you this I'm
going to give you brand I'm going to
give you all of these things and I'm
going to let you run this department and
I'm going to let you lead these things
but you've never done that we've done
that sure of course we've done that how
have you done that Ivan runs the YouTube
channel right but but not inventing new
content yeah he is he's coming with new
ideas he doesn't come up with all the
new ideas he comes up with new ideas he
he creates Pilots he runs them he
launches them he reports back what's
working and not working yeah we do we do
a monthly meeting where we look at
everything that's worked and worked and
not worked in the past two months we
look at the
series we have our winning series and we
have a test series every week that
mostly he's coming up with ideas for but
it's it's collaboration and how long do
you let those run out before you
determine if they're they working or not
usually at least three episodes cuz like
parks and rack TV show admittedly took a
season to find its voice the office took
a season and a half to find its voice um
there's so many uh different pieces of
like more creative type stuff where it
just it just takes time to figure out
and crap the not so like three is the
starting point and then from there we
look at how hard is this to
make and can we is there enough to turn
this into something like is this
something like a top 10 we were actually
struggling when we only were doing
entrepreneurs but then if we expanded
the list to athletes and musicians and
whatever like oh okay this is doable top
10 was only once a week then it became
twice a week and then became every day
because like is this something I can
scale or not so is the idea is something
that can scale or not we think it is we
don't launch an idea if we don't think
it it can scale I mean if we had a
one-off sure we do lots of crazy
one-offs but how much do we think we can
scale uh and like assuming the data
flops right then okay did we love it
though like can we tweak something can
we change it do we do we still love the
idea was it just that the first minute
sucked yeah like the ideas that we love
more will play more with yeah trying to
figure out so I think your greatest
opportunity for
growth if that's what you want you have
this big Vision but I don't I don't hear
you saying like I really want growth but
your biggest opportunity for growth I
believe after watching you for all these
years is to look at all the different
way is is is to really turn your YouTube
channel into more of a media Empire
right and so there's audio form there's
written form there's article forms
there's short form there's all of this
stuff that you have short form would
take very seriously I don't short form
video sorry I mean I mean like like
taking taking pieces of content and then
splitting it out into these X threads or
whatever Twitter wants to be called now
and like just like like looking like
moving away from solely video taking the
different assets taking the different
learning patching packaging it up to
meet all of these different people in
all of these different areas but really
putting putting like leaders in charge
of each of these things moving yourself
out of an owner
operator to to more of of of a CEO and
and that's not what you have to do
because you've told me like I don't have
to do this things I like what I'm doing
and I don't want to do these things so I
don't it's it's the opportunity but but
all of the opportunities front of you
are the ones that you just have no
interest in
pursuing yeah I mean that those are
actually not that difficult to do like
to take to really if I really want to
blow up on Twitter or LinkedIn or
whatever I'm already making the long
film content on YouTube because you want
to hit that that massive goal which is
why I keep hearing that like you're more
interested in working towards the goal
as long as it's making the stuff that
you want to make the way you want to
make it yeah I guess it's uh
aggressively going and finding the right
person you know like we could we could
train somebody up or you hire somebody
to go off and you don't have to because
you have you have the brand you have the
potential and you have the resources to
go out there and find these amazing
people who have done this before yeah
you're so finding somebody as opposed to
you can go and steal someone from K Nast
right which is the parent company of
like all of these massive online
Publications see now you're smiling a
little bit because you're like what why
would the hell would I do that they come
they n to do social media but yes no I
hear you you could take it's it's
committing the time and energy to go
find the person so that to play so
that's a
play other social media content a play
you know branding and and you know
selling hoodies and merch and in certain
fashion line is a play there's lots of
plays it's like the right one at the
right time I guess that's the challenge
right it's like but the real unlock is
is is doing it even if you
personally I hate the word apathetic
because that's not what it is it's just
not being attached to it you're not
making it for you and the audience there
are times to just make things for your
customers and your audience and not
always for you and that's okay it will
move you closer towards your goal and if
your goal is to make more money which
it's not it will move you closer to your
goal if you want to have more
impact you can have more impact if if if
you didn't have to check all of those
boxes all the time I think in the short
term yes but in the long term I would
just quit on it so that you wouldn't
have to quit on it because you wouldn't
be doing it I wouldn't be doing it I
mean it's still part of what I'm
doing like I don't want to go and look
at something that we're making and not
feel proud of what we're making
indifferent which was your word
apathetic is not a lack of Pride it's
it's an emotional Detachment let's say
like should we be in schools sure yeah
we should be in schools we should have
educational content who's teaching
entrepreneurs in schools cool uh would I
partner with somebody to get into
schools yeah like I'm not I'm not going
to take it to schools it's like I have
no interest in taking it to schools and
and working out the Behemoth of like
figuring out how the education system to
like zero interest but there's someone
out there has the education background
who who would who would love to do this
and impact people I would still so would
I partner with that person yes do I
invest my energy now to go find that
person is that the best use of my time
versus like other things it's not
interesting enough but if I had the
right person I would do it but I would
still want to like the content that
we're putting in the schools like
obviously listen to yes like the content
you're putting into schools yeah is this
the the cost benefit is this the best
use of my time that cost benefit
thinking that data driven decision-
making that like it has to fix these
boxes will always discount these things
that I data though not data at all it's
heart like that might be the biggest
data play of all yes I just
don't feel called to it but you want to
impact I know how how many people do you
want to impact logically it makes sense
yeah the whole world logically it makes
sense yeah I just don't get called to it
heart more head well no I that's why you
suck I suck cuz I'm I'm too fashioned
driven how much would it cost to do this
school thing like let's let's say like
if you had to hire the great people and
build a team like 500k I don't know but
it's not the money cost it's the time
cost because because even if they're
going to do it I have to meet them and I
have to I want to be proud of what we're
putting into the the school so I have to
look at the content not every single
decision on there but I'm going to be
involved in the thing let's say it cost
you a million dollars it's not the money
Mark let's say it took you a year and a
half I don't want to spend a year impact
an entire Next Generation to have what
you that's a logical way of looking at
it yes you need to be more logical
sometimes I from from I want to be
emotionally connected to the projects
that I'm doing okay well there you go
that could be why I suck or I could just
not have the right person around me who
can pull out the emotional ideas or find
the right ones that I will be
emotionally connected to I mean that's
what I'm I'm pinging ideas off of
everybody like hey how about you got an
idea for me you got an idea for me you
got an idea for me who's got an idea
I've got an idea like you talk she's
here from India she she's a year into
being in Canada and she sent me an email
and I I connected with her I like hey
come to the I don't know what we can do
together but come come to my restaurant
for three days and like see what you get
to know what I do and see if there's
something that we can work on together
right so she's learning and and pitching
different ideas and we haven't like hit
the one maybe she's frustrated like hey
come with an idea well you're in the
same boat as Mark now I was trying to
but but that's I do get ideas not just
for me and like that is the right hire
that is the person I need the most it's
the person who can understand marketing
opportunities but also my heart and what
I'm missing and like give me the right
idea to be able to go off and do it
consistently well there you go that's my
hire now how do I find that person
that's another episode thank you
Mark to see my last tell me why I suck
episode with Devon bison the NBA mindset
coach check the video right there next
to me I think you love but continue to
believe and I'll see you there so that's
the mind the mind is like a GPS it's a
computer it's someone wakes up has a cou
of coffee they break the cup of coffee
and they usually say I'm going to have a
bad day